so why do residents work so well let's
go through one example that illustrates
why residents work so well at least in
the sense of how you can make them
deeper and deeper without really hurting
your ability to at least get them to do
well on the training set and hopefully
as you've understood from the third
course in the sequence doing well on the
training set is usually a prerequisite
to doing well on your holdout or on your
death or on your test sets so being able
to at least training resident to do well
on the training set is a good first step
toward that let's look at an example
what we saw in the last video was that
if you make a network deeper it can hurt
your ability to train the network to do
well on the training set and that's why
sometimes you don't want a network that
is too deep but this is not true or at
least is much less true when you're
training a resident so let's go through
an example let's say you have X feeding
in to some big neural network and this
outputs some activation al let's say for
this example that you're gonna modify it
in your network to make it a little bit
deeper so you're the same big an end and
this outputs al and we're going to add a
couple extra layers to this network so
let's add one layer there and another
layer there and this will output a o+ to
only let's make this a resonant block a
residual block with that extra shortcut
and for the sake of argument let's say
throughout this network we're using the
value activation function so all the
activations are going to be you know
greater than or equal to zero with a
positive exception of the input X right
because the value activation outputs
numbers are either zero or positive now
let's look at what al plus two will be
so copy the
freshen from the previous video al plus
2 will be rarely applied to Z L plus 2
and then plus al where this addition of
Al comes from the short circuit from the
skipped connection that we just added
and if we expand this out this is equal
to G of WL plus 2 times a of L plus 1
plus BL plus 2 so that's ZL plus 2 is
equal to that plus al now notice
something if you are using l2
regularization or weight decay that will
tend to shrink the value of WL + 2 um if
you're applying weight decay to B that
will also strengthen Saul though I guess
in practice sometimes you do and
sometimes you don't apply weight to K to
B but W is really the key term to pay
attention to here and if WL plus 2 is
equal to zero and let's say for the sake
of argument that B is also equal to zero
then these terms go away because they
equal to zero and then G of Al this is
just equal to Al right because we
assumed we're using the value activation
function and so all the activations are
non-negative and so G of ALS the value
applied to a non-negative quantity so
you just get back al so what this shows
is that the identity function is easy
for residual block to learn and it's
easy to get al plus 2 equal to Al
because of this skipped connection and
what that means is that having these two
layers in your network it doesn't really
hurt your neural networks ability to do
as well as this simpler network without
these two extra
because it's quite easy for it to learn
the identity function to just copy a L
to L plus 2 using despite the addition
of these two layers and this is why
adding two extra layers having this
residual block to the somewhere in the
middle or to the end of this big neural
network
it doesn't hurt performance but of
course our goal is to not just not hurt
performance as the whole performance and
so you can imagine that if all of these
hidden units if they actually learned
something useful then maybe you can do
even better than learning the identity
function and what goes wrong in very
deep plane nets in very deep networks
without these message all these skipped
connections is that when you need make
the network deeper and deeper is
actually very difficult for it to choose
parameters that learn even the identity
function which is why a lot of layers
end up making your result worse rather
than making a result better and I think
the main reason the residual network
works is that is so easy for these extra
layers to learn the residual to learn
the identity function that you have kind
of guaranteed that it doesn't hurt
performance and then you know a lot of
time you maybe get lucky and it even
helps performance or this is easier to
go from a decent baseline of not hurting
performance and then gradient descent
can only improve the solution from there
it's one more detail in the residual
Network that's worth discussing which is
through this addition here we're
assuming that ZL plus 2 and al have the
same dimension and so what you see in
resonance is a lot of use of same
convolutions so that the dimension of
this is equal to the dimension I guess
of this layer of the output layer so
that you can actually do this short
circuit connection because the same
convolution preserves dimensions and so
it makes it easier for you to you know
carry out to have this a short circuit
and then carry out this edition of too
equal dimension vectors um in case the
input and output have different
dimensions so for example if this is
hundred and twenty eight dimensional and
Z or therefore al is 256 dimensional as
an example what you would do is add an
extra matrix they call that ws over here
and WS in this example would be a 256 by
128 dimensional matrix so then WS x al
becomes 256 dimensional and this
addition is now between two to five six
dimensional vectors and a few things you
could do if W s it could be a matrix of
parameters to be learned via fixed
matrix that just implement zero padding
so it takes al and then zero pads it to
be 256 dimensional and either of those
versions I guess could work so finally
let's take a look at resonance on images
so these are images I got from the paper
by her at all this is an example of a
plane Network and in which you input an
image and then have a number of
conflicts until eventually you have a
soft max output at the end to turn this
into a ResNet you add those extra
skipped connections and I just mention a
few details there are a lot of 3x3
convolutions here and all these most of
these are 3x3 same convolutions and
that's why you're adding your equal
dimension feature vectors so rather than
they fully commit to layer these are
actually convolutional layers but
because there are same convolutions the
dimension is preserved and so the ZL
plus 2 plus al right edition makes sense
and similar to what you've seen in a lot
of networks before you have a bunch of
convolutional layers and then in there
occasionally
pulling layers as well or pulling or
pulling like layers
and whenever one of those things happen
then you need to make an adjustment to
the dimension which we saw on the
previous slide you can do of the matrix
W s and then as is common in these
networks you have cough cough cough or
come from harmful come from Kanpur and
then at the end you know have a fully
connected layer that then makes a
prediction using a soft max so that's it
for resonance of Nyx
there's a very interesting idea behind
using neural networks with one by one
filters one by one convolutions so what
good is a one by one convolution let's
take a look at the next video